people on earth like to talk a lot about
colonizing Mars but what if it had
already happened and the first humans
had already settled down on the Red
Planet what would life on Mars look like
would we be able to live on the surface
or have to hide underground from all the
solar radiation that Mars gets exposed
to would we be able to terraform it this
is what if and here's what would happen
if we lived on Mars ever felt like
getting off this planet well consider
Mars fourth Rock from the Sun it can be
as close as fifty six million kilometres
away it can also be as far as 401
million kilometres away even if you
jumped into the fastest spacecraft ever
launched from Earth getting there would
take anywhere from 40 days to nine and a
half months depending on the position of
the planets and after all that time
spent in space you'd finally see dry and
lifeless Mars on the horizon would you
be able to survive there what would you
need to survive on Mars anyway first off
you'd have to figure out how to produce
oxygen to breathe the Martian atmosphere
is very thin and it's 95% carbon dioxide
you wouldn't be able to just bring the
oxygen you need to survive but you could
extract it from the carbon dioxide with
machines like NASA's moxie
not only would that provide you and
other Martian settlers with breathable
air but also supply you with liquid
oxygen propellant that's the stuff you'd
need to lift a rocket off Mars in case
you decided to return to Earth there's
no fertile soil on Mars to grow food in
instead you'd use hydroponics
cultivating your crops in a mineral and
nutrient solution no soil required of
course without running water on the
surface your colony would only be able
to grow 20% of the food you'd need the
rest of it you'd have shipped in from
Earth but don't expect fresh meat all
your food would come dried
along with the other settlers you'd
probably live in inflatable pressurized
buildings but it's more likely that
you'd go underground because Mars has no
global geomagnetic field and since its
atmosphere is so thin radiation levels
in the orbit above Mars are two and a
half times higher than at the
International Space Station
that's too much solar radiation for
humans to bear
forget about Sun Tanning the Sun would
appear just half as big as it does from
Earth and if you want to go outside and
return alive you'd need a spacesuit to
make up for the near absent atmospheric
pressure and to block radiation your
suit would also keep you warm which is
important because temperatures on Mars
are very low the coldest winter on Earth
is paradise compared to the average
Martian winter temperatures would be as
low as 55 degrees below zero even colder
at the poles where the temperatures can
drop to a freezing
- 153 degrees a day on Mars is just 40
minutes longer than a day on earth a
year on Mars would be almost twice as
long though if you lived in the northern
hemisphere you'd enjoy seven months of
spring and six months of summer then
there would be a five month long autumn
and another four months of winter
and not only are the temperatures their
low they can also change dramatically
within a week these variations often
result in powerful dust storms they
wouldn't harm you but they'd clog all
your electronics remember too that the
gravity on Mars is about one-third of
Earth's you'd need to learn how to walk
again still want to move to the Red
Planet
well your best bet is to wait until the
first human colonies head there to
terraform the planet to make it just
like the one they came from
they'd import ammonia ice from the
atmospheres of other planets to heat
Mars up a little the heat would convert
the dry ice at the Martian North Pole
into gas and give the planet an
atmosphere still unbreathable for us but
at least it would be enough to create
atmospheric pressure so that you could
finally take off your spacesuit then
they'd extract water from the vast
reserves of water ice locked beneath
Mars a surface water vapor would make
the atmosphere thicker and thicker
eventually you'd see it raining and
snowing on Mars and after maybe a
thousand years there'd be enough oxygen
for humans to breathe the planet
reengineering would be complete is
living on mars something you'd like to
try or would you rather preserve what we
have here on earth